ten years president says he will soon
issue an executive order authorizing
sanctions against current and former
Turkish officials in response to turkeys
military offensive into northern Syria
Donald Trump says he will also stop
negotiations with Ankara on a 100
billion dollar trade deal and boost
tariffs on Turkish steel to 50 percent
he also said the thousand American
troops leaving in Syria will stay in the
region to prevent ISIL making a comeback
rights getting more on all of this from
Heidi Joe Castro she joins us live in
Washington let's start with this
executive order what more can you tell
us Heidi Oh Barbara we know that the
White House intends to sign this
executive order in its words soon and
that what President Trump would be
ordering is the imposition of sanctions
on former and current high-level Turkish
officials it would raise steel tariffs
back to 50% and end negotiations on a
trade deal with Turkey worth about a
hundred billion dollars now it does not
the statement itself announcing this
executive order does not name the
Kurdish by name however it does say that
it's accusing the Turkish of targeting
of ethnic and religious minorities is
unacceptable now immediately after the
White House released this statement via
Trump's Twitter feed a defense secretary
mark espera also released his own
statement saying that Turkey has taken
irresponsible actions putting the risk
to US forces in Southeast serious in
Northeast Syria rather at unacceptable
levels he goes on to say therefore at
the president's direction the defense
the Department of Defense is executing a
deliberate withdrawal of US military
personnel now it's interesting how he
adds that therefore because of course as
we all know it was the president's
decision to withdraw US troops before
turkey had started its ground operation
in northern Syria and in fact Trump
himself said that he had given the
president of Turkey a green light before
Turkish troops arrived
at the border now Trump in his
announcement about this executive order
goes on to say that Turkey will now or
in the future may be responsible for the
ongoing detention of ISIL prisoners in
Syria and he announced that the US would
maintain a small footprint with some
troops stationed in southern Syria and
that US troops who have been ordered to
withdraw from north northern Syria will
now redeploy and remain in the region to
monitor the situation Barbara okay so
interesting to see you know how more of
this will develop over the next days or
so but just remind us how much pressure
the president has been over this since
he announced the u.s. troops withdrawal
from northern Syria because even people
that are normally his supporters in the
Senate all the way have been critical of
his action here
absolutely arguably Trump's biggest
supporter is senator Mitch McConnell a
notable senator in the Republican Party
and he prior to the announcement of
these sanctions issued a pretty grave
statement saying he was concerned by the
recent events in Syria and the US
response thus far he warned of a broader
power vacuum that will be exploited by
Iran and Russia in his words a
catastrophic outcome for the US
strategic interests and it is
interesting that he has been pushing
back pretty consistently ever since
Trump entertained the idea of removing
US troops in Syria back in December
leading up to this point meanwhile Trump
has been firing off these mixed messages
because just hours prior to declaring
that he would sign this executive order
he also took to Twitter saying anyone
who wants to assist Syria and protecting
the Kurds is good with me
whether it is Russia China or Napoleon
Bonaparte Barbara Heidi Joe Castro with
the latest on that from Washington Heidi
as always thank you